are you talking about are you ignorant
no listen I asked one question in a
minute you're I asked the man I said
look this is under God truth I said look
bro the uh plug ain't working cuz I was
trying to plug in my
computer like I got I got witnesses I
got 20 witnesses that was sitting there
right beside
me S only thing I asked for the plug is
not working can I get another plug he
like up I didn't say okay normally we're
going to have this discussion up top cuz
other people have to go off the
plan
talks and let's go cuz I don't mind
going to jail know
that cuz you ain't my
dad
[Music]
WR you're underr I'm not I know I know
you're not I know you're not stand up
it makes it EAS for only thing I'm
saying is I told the man I said I'm just
trying to plug in my charger I'm getting
locked up for plugging in do me a favor
and put your wrist together so this
don't hurt you okay let them stand up
let them stand up go ahead go ahead
y'all drunk go ahead keep your wrist
together you can give me a drug test bro
I everybody who look these for recording
y'all y'all know that right we're y'all
see
this make sure that one's a little tired
turn around I got you turn around it's
5:30 a.m. y'all think I'm drunk y'all
sound stupid okay y could have gave me a
test and ask me was I drunk bro you
ain't got to do
this there we go just go back down to
the car and go all right can I get can
we get
my out first we grab it I'm asking you a
question can you pull up my
pants y'all tripping
man like I'm I'm good I got you listen
I'm
listening
only I can't wait to do this
test they everybody get sued come on let
me go got grab myself I don't need y'all
to grab me let me
I can walk myself I can walk myself I
can walk myself I don't need y'all to
ground me okay like what are we doing
like like we should have a conversation
bro big dog can I talk to you for one no
you ain't talking to
me you had a chance to have your
conversation you chose not listen to me
you're
right I'm cool with it because when when
we do this blow test when we do this
blow test I'm suing everybody uh I'm can
I ask y'all one question before we
go I
ask y act like I'm somewhere look we're
out here with
airplan trying to okay you can talk well
you don't need to I want to
talk what are y'all locking me up for a
minut what what's my Tarts disorderly
conduct and
AI I'm not drunk okay that's fine can I
take a blow test no have a seat seat no
blow test have a seat have a seat please
Glide your feet in bro can I ask yall
one no no I
know I know for real put Fe lick at me
bro can I can Hey listen listen bro I'm
asking you a question I know you all
right
listen you going to pull him through put
your feet in or he's going to pull you
in can I talk to you for one second you
have the
opportunity so y'all you
get it's wrong that's all I'm going tell
y'all sit back sit back so I can seat
Bel you in all you going to seat Bel me
in with my hands in the back yes or can
I put them in the front
cuz
what's your name Janine Janine I'm suing
you he definitely getting
sued you doing all
that don't touch
me man y'all let him
do I know you hate me so can I ask a
question mark yeah you you do but
there's no way no you can't even tell me
a reason why you got me back here you
said I was drunk balize me I'm not drunk
then what what's your next option are
[Applause]
you it's just waste of bro like you just
only thing I'm saying is you accused me
of my background not of me right now you
accus you accusing me of what you
thought I was and what I ain't go ahead
I'm listening go ahead you arrested for
disorderly conduct for what I didn't say
what's the what's the rule of disorderly
conduct tell me what's the rule for you
to lock somebody up for disorderly
conduct bro for AI you like Al what is
AI breiz me I'm not drunk okay how the
you going to lock me up for aloy and you
ain't bre Iz me you sound stupid as it's
6: a.m. in the morning I had one drink
which was a Peno greo go to the bar ask
him you
stupid that's my point to you you're
going to get
fired the talking about how the am I
drunk I drove to the airport and have
one panut REO don't go out last night
and you you you you come about I'm drunk
bro come on bro like I'm just I'm like
really I'm asking you to do your
homework before you just
assume what these people are saying and
I specifically told
you I was in the seat only thing I asked
the do
bro hey
yo is it a uh is the the plug working or
can you move me to another
seat that's the only thing I asked him
so he left he came back and I was like
so what that mean he's like we're going
back to the
gate bro you would have have like you
don't have not one person that
complained about me on the airplane like
how are you going to win this in
court like do you think this Fair
brother to do this just to up my
reputation you don't give a probably you
don't bro and that's the point that I
got like you doing this just just me
up not even thinking about what I do for
my family or what I got going on then
you just automatically say I'm drunk
give me a test you got a
blur you know why you want to give me a
blur cuz you know I ain't
drunk if you had any idea that you
thought I was drunk
you be like I pack
blow come on bro like this ain't right
bro and I tell you if I was wrong I
didn't bro I'm asking about a charger on
the plane for my
iPad dad do you hear me come on man like
like this what's going to happen to your
son career we going it all
up yeah it is it's going to it all up
because a black man don't like white
people going to do the same thing that
you doing to
me cuz that's what you doing to me this
ain't got nothing to do with if wrong or
right cuz you know goddamn wrong I mean
you know goddamn right I ain't wrong if
I was wrong every last person on that
plane would have came out and say
something not one person got a complaint
how in the all the officers got a
complaint with no no complaint from the
mother people that's on the plane come
on man like this ain't right bro this is
not
right this ain't right like at at a
certain point bro we got to do better by
each other and do right like if you
think it's right lock me up I'm cool we
getting locked up for no
reason but bro I
know I know I I had one
drink bro I ain't no ain't nobody drunk
I ain't yelled I ain't disrespecting
nobody only thing I told the man was
even the lady beside me it's a a old
lady s she said they locking you up they
going
back and you got mad because when I was
walking through the hallway and I was
like bro you locking me up for nothing
guess what you tell me you you made the
decision though going to jail that's
what you
said for what tell me why you made that
decision can you tell
me
oh issues you done yet
or somebody yall got some weed y'all got
the
weed
so can I ask you one question no I'm
done cuz you know you wrong right
on camera now a it's on camera how you
grabb me at the door for no reason I'm
in handcuffs you grab me like I'm trying
to fight
you you were trying to get out of bro
you thought how I'm going get out of the
car bro sck your you thought I was going
to get out the car so that mean you you
should punch me right you should should
punch me for getting out the car I
didn't punch you you're a goddamn
Li now you going to beat me up when we
get to the jail tell all your homeboys
oh pack coming in there let's beat him
up BR like is so wrong bro like and I'm
the best mother dude in the world bro I
have to go
through crazy bro I'm the same
motherucker who going to give your kids
mother
scholarships who mother take your
everybody in the mother
neighborhood crazy it's all good though
you know
what I'm cool with it but I want you to
know when you go to sleep tonight and
you roll over in the morning ain't no
way you can say this right bro bro
listen I'm going to bro I'm going to
jail for being on the plane bro I didn't
even yell at nobody bro cuz come on bro
look at me can you look at me one second
just look at me in my eye if you tell me
I'm wrong I could listen I can respect
huh you're wrong for
what for your behavior what Behavior
being disorderly disrespecting other
officers disrespecting the flight
attendance causing the aircraft to be
turned around hey bro first of all I
shut up I didn't even say nothing when
you see the film you going to feel like
a that's first and foremost cuz I never
said nothing on the aircraft he told me
he said
hey if you don't shut up B we going to
turn right CRA I said you know what I
ain't going to say nothing even the lady
beside
me you the only one they got aggressive
and grabbed me when we went out of
there bro I got it on camera do you
think I travel by
myself all
right
set hey can I get your name what's your
name big
bro hey big bro boss
man boss
man can I talk to y'all for one second
can you let the window down I know I'm
going to jail I don't give a about that
can I talk for one second that's all I'm
asking
can I talk to y'all for one
secondy excuse
me can I talk to y'all for one second or
not big
dog big dog I'm actually you one Hey
listen hey big dog I know I'm going to
jail we is cool can can I at least talk
to them for one
second I can't say nothing
right bro did I do something to you you
mad to me you are you are let's make
sure we on camera what did I do to
you this driv is the racist no the driv
is the
racist what's wrong with you man bro
what's wrong with you
what the is wrong with
you hey you're a racist crack hey say
that say how racist you
is bro this is wrong bro bro you really
think bro like I hope your kids go you
know what I hope your kids go
through racist
Pig I hope your kids go through
this if your kids was going through this
for s on the plane and not
saying how would you feel
bro
you hey
yo I want to take a breath of
Lo hey
yo
bro you so wrong
bro it's so
wrong y so
wrong I want to take a breath for
love
hey bro y'all are wrong
bro y'all
wrong y'all
wrong
hey what's his
name hey hey hey you going to lose your
job
you going to lose your job tomorrow you
going to lose your what's your
name where's your ID what's your name
where is your
ID give me a breath a l you saying I'm
drunk
about
yo you cannot search my
yo
bro hey
bro I got them on me they on me hey yo
yo
yo hey yo I got my driver license I got
yeah I got
them
bro you tripping which pocket is it all
right can you let me out no bro it ain't
nobody but you bro okay what's your name
Au little you a bro and then you give me
a breath for L if you think I'm drunk at
one drink okay stupid it's 6: a.m. in
the morning who the going to be drunk in
the morning
want man yeah because you want me to be
drunk you doing this because you want
you want recognition no yeah you is you
ain't doing your job you're a
SL
my bro listen this only thing why would
I is nobody saying that I'm going crazy
in there why would you do that just un
can you hear me
out bro I gave you oh I gave you the opp
I don't even want to hear your side
anymore why not because you're already
under arrest I know but hold on can I
hear keep your can I ask you one
question go
ahead no for real
like what have I did to D disorderly
contact for the plane to return to no I
didn't they did that only thing I asked
was I asked one question can you hear me
out one question I asked one you ask me
I'm trying to answer your question if
you don't want to listen to my answer
then I'm done with this conversation but
I'm this
man this is
so this can't be right
bro this can't be
right you
f
oh